hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nights at Freddy's 3
ahh what's happening okay it's over then
I'm sure I'm alive what am i alive
Finley's I thought I rebooted that game
over okay that's what I expected to
happen
what I didn't expect happen was
everything else hey what the [ __ ] is
that what am I gonna do
well okay bye so yeah he's back in five
so I can skin him back to six should be
fine
4 a.m. plenty of time Freddy come on in
we'll have a nice tea party and then he
can go [ __ ] himself the ventilation
system goes out in that son of a [ __ ]
oh hey hey hey I was just talking about
you we had the best time you remember
you remember back when you I told you to
go [ __ ] yourself and you didn't oh I
thought that was a very clever choice
you know you know staring into your eyes
this long scientists prove that it
builds a connection between two people
all in all the lights may be blaring but
I'd like to think about the red-hot
burning love that I feel in my heart for
you yeah ooba-dooba doop do I love you
at all great apparently somehow hey
balloony okay well then she used her she
wants to serve me a cupcake I think it
was pizza
you